DO YOU THINK THEY WILL SUE
THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND FOR
SIDING FOR MS-13 OVER
AMERICAN CITIZENS?
DON'T HOLD YOUR BREATH.
KRIS KOBACH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE OF KANSAS AND HE JOINS
US TONIGHT.
MR. KOBACH, THANKS FOR COME
ON.
>> GREAT TO BE WITH YOU
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I JUST WANT TO BE
TOTALLY CLEAR ON THIS AND,
AGAIN, I HATE BECAUSE I
REALLY THINK PEOPLE OUGHT TO
HAVE A CHANCE TO RESPOND TO
WHAT YOU SAY ABOUT THEM.
I'M SORRY THE ALDERMAN
♪ER WHO.
WE HAD A LONG CONVERSATION
WITH HIM LAST NIGHT AND HE
TOLD US THREE TIMES I'M
EXPERT ON ELECTORAL LAW IN
THE STATE OF ILLINOIS.
YOU HAVE TO PROVE YOU ARE A
CITIZEN OF THE COUNTRY TO IN
ORDER TO REGISTER TO VOTE.
IS THAT TRUE?
>> THAT IS FALSE.
ANYONE WHO STUDIES THIS
ISSUE KNOWS THERE ARE ONLY
FOUR STATES WHERE THE LAWS
REQUIRE TO YOU PROVIDE PROOF
OF CITIZENSHIP WHEN YOU
REGISTER TO VOTE.
THOSE STATES ARE KANSAS,
ARIZONA, ALABAMA, AND
GEORGIA.
AND OF THOSE FOUR, ONLY
KANSAS AND ARIZONA HAVE
FULLY IMPLEMENTED THE LAW.
THE OTHER TWO STATES ARE IN
THE PROCESS OF STARTING TO
IMPLEMENT THE LAW.
>> Tucker: JUST TO BE CLEAR,
WHAT YOU DO NEED IN EVERY
STATE IS A GOVERNMENT I.D.,
UNIVERSALLY GOVERNMENT I.D.
HARD FOR ILLEGAL ALIENS TO
GET BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE.
>> YES.
>> Tucker: GOVERNOR GIVES
THEM I.D. SUFFICIENT FOR
VOTER REGISTRATION HOW ARE
THEY NOT ABETTING VOTER
FRAUD.
>> IT IS ABSOLUTELY ABETTING
VOTER FRAUD.
THE AMAZING THING IS OF
COURSE IN THE OTHER 46
STATES, YOU DON'T NEED TO
PROVIDE PROOF OF
CITIZENSHIP.
ALL YOU NEED TO DO IS CHECK
A BOX THAT SAYS I AM A U.S.
CITIZEN.
AND WE HAVE FOUND HUNDREDS
OF CASES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY, WE HAVE HAD EXPERT
WITNESSES LOOK AT KANSAS AND
IT COULD BE AS HIGH AS
18,000 ALIENS ON OUR VOTER
ROLES IN OTHER STATES IT'S
PROBABLY IN THE SIX FIGURES
OR MORE.
BUT THE POINT IS PEOPLE ARE
DOING THIS ALL THE TIME.
SOMETIMES INTENTIONALLY,
SOMETIMES THE NONCITIZENS
ARE DOING IT
UNINTENTIONALLY.
THEY CAN'T EVEN READ WHAT IT
IS THEY HAVE JUST SIGNED.
OR THEY DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION
TO IT.
AND THEN THEY START GETTING
MAIL FROM THE CANDIDATE
SAYING, HEY, YOU ARE A
REGISTERED VOTER.
DON'T FORGET TO VOTE FOR ME
ON AUGUST 7TH OR WHATEVER
THE DATE IS THEY ARE
REGISTERING AND THEY ARE
VOTING.
>> Tucker: WHY WOULDN'T THAT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN
ELECTIONS?
CLEARLY THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
IS ABETTING.
THIS DOING THIS ON PURPOSE.
PRINTING IDS ON PUBLIC
EXPENSE GIVING THEM TO
ILLEGALS AND LETTING THEM
REGISTER TO VOTE.
WHY?
NOT ELECTORAL STRATEGY?
IT LOOKS LIKE THAT.
>> IT CERTAINLY LOOKS THAT
WAY.
IT DOES SEEM THAT MANY IN
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HOPEFULLY NOT ALL, SEEM TO
THINK THAT IT'S OKAY IF
ALIENS VOTE AND YEAH, MAYBE,
THEY SHOULDN'T BE BUT, HECK
IT, HELPS THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ANYWAY.
SOME OF THEM HAVE TALKED
LIKE THAT.
I THINK IT'S APPALLING.
LOOK, ONLY AMERICANS ARE
ALLOWED TO VOTE IN THESE
ELECTIONS.
YOU WIN OR LOSE BY
PERSUADING AMERICANS THAT
YOUR POLICIES ARE RIGHT.
THE IDEA THAT WE WOULD TRY
TO REPLACE OR OUTWEIGH
AMERICAN VOTERS BY BRINGING
IN FOREIGN VOTERS IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE
FOREIGN INFLUENCE SCANDAL.
YOU ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF A
LAWSUIT OVER SOMETHING
RELATED TO THIS.
>> YEAH.
YEAH.
SO THE ACLU HAS KIND OF
DECLARED WAR ON ELECTION
SECURITY LAWS LIKE OURS IN
KANSAS.
AND THIS WAR IS SOMETHING
THAT IS OUTRAGEOUS.
THEY ARE MAKING RIDICULOUS
ARGUMENTS LIKE IT'S
UNCONSTITUTIONAL BURDEN FOR
YOU TO REACH INTO YOUR FILE
CABINET AT HOME TO FIND YOUR
BIRTH CERTIFICATE OR
CLAIMING THAT THE NATIONAL
VOTER LAW OF 1993 SOMEHOW
CREATED A SPECIAL PRIVILEGE
IF YOU GET YOUR LICENSE AT
DMV YOU DON'T HAVE TO PROVE
CITIZENSHIP EVEN THOUGH THE
LAW DOESN'T SAY THAT CRAZY
ARGUMENTS BUT WE ARE
FIGHTING THEM IN COURT NEXT
WEEK.
>> Tucker: I HOPE IT'S CLEAR
TO OUR AUDIENCE WHAT THE
POINT OF THIS IS BECAUSE IT
IS CLEAR.
MR. SECRETARY, THANKS FOR
COMING ON.
WE APPRECIATE IT?
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Tucker: ACTING ICE
DIRECTOR THOMAS HOMAN SPOKE
FRANKLY WHAT OAKLAND MAYOR
LIBBY SCHAAF DID WHEN SHE
WARNED OF THE IMPENDING
RAIDS IN OUR I IS IT, WATCH.
>> WHAT SHE DID NO BETTER
THAN A GANG LOOKOUT YELLING
POLICE WHEN A POLICE CRUISER
COMES IN A NEIGHBORHOOD
EXCEPT SHE DID IT TO THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
IT'S BEYOND THE PALE.
I HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
34 YEARS.
AND THIS IS A WHOLE NEW LOW
TO INTENTIONALLY WARN